pourquoi je comprends la haine la haine
anti-flic simplement que disait ce que
disait monsieur sur ces crimes
c'est qu'ils sont jusqu'à présent pour
la plupart impunis des crimes de
policiers des crimes policiers c'est
très grave ce que vous dites comment
c'est très grave ce que vous dites parce
que on a parlé tout à l'heure d'affaires
qui ne sont toujours pas terminés et les
affaires qui ont été cités ne sont pas
terminées mais il ya des offert au fort
du oui qui sont terminées et il ya eu
aussi parfois des condamnations oui mais
donc il ya des affaires en cours alors
si le mot crime crime ne vous convient
pas on va utiliser le fonctionnement
sont là c'est donc c'est les violences
policières dans les banlieues
quand on dit beaulieu s'est pas
uniquement uniquement les cités on va
parler voilà deux villes comme ça qu'ils
sont qui sont excentrés donc et moi je
vais parler notamment de mantes la jolie
lorsqu'il ya ce genre d'affrontement
vous pensez sincèrement qu'un gamin
quand ils se lèvent le matin il dit je
vais brûler une poubelle
et en plus vous parler d'éducation vous
pensez vous pensez sérieusement que les
pièces à voile à sa caisse qui qu'est ce
qui lui passe par la tête
alors qu'est ce qu'ils se disaient ils
se disent c'est une vengeance alors 10-0
la textualité eux depuis depuis de
nombreuses années parce que là on parle
de ce qui s'est passé à mi-octobre à
mantes la jolie et plus généralement
dans les yvelines
ce climat de tension qui qui montent
comme ça jusqu aux affrontements
il est entretenu il a entretenu par
l'omniprésence de la police dans les
quartiers à mantes-la-jolie notamment au
val fourré donc on parle souvent de
sous-effectif
donc non on voit le four il n'y a pas de
on a constamment les policiers de la bac
on a constamment différentes brigades
qui interviennent régulièrement qui sont
omniprésents c'est à dire que la
présence policière fait partie de la
quotidienneté des habitants du val
fourré on a des enfants qui sont
contrôlés régulièrement au faciès qui
sont pas le p lorsqu'ils se rendent sur
les chemins de l'école payer ça et ça ce
que vous essayez de nous dire c'est que
c'est en fait c'est le voilà de voir
tout le temps la présence policière
c'est quoi ça les temps ils sentent
oppressés ils se sentent volaille ceci
ils se disent voilà on est il ya deux
poids deux mesures parce que pourquoi
ils sont ils sont chez nous c'est ça
mais pourquoi ils sont chez nous leur
présente comment elle s'explique comment
s exc
quand le quartier calme quand vous avez
des fonctionnaires de police qui qui
provoque ce qui provoque la jeunesse des
quartiers pensez vraiment pardon vous
pensez vraiment que donc il ya de la
provocation
derrière de l'ordre il ya des extraits
ovale pour et voilà par exemple pour
provoquer des jeunes mais dans quel but
mais tout ça quels intérêts mais sans
qu'elle puisse l'emporter mais là où on
peut trouver en elle voudrait comprendre
l'intérêt et ça ne me suis pas très
important de poser des repères pour des
policiers de venir au bas des tours
lorsque des jeunes pourquoi troupes et
discutent entre eux ce jeu de
provocation est ce qu ils sont agressifs
voilà les votants sont des policiers des
policiers les bleus lycées sont agressés
une agression répond à une agression
c'est à dire qu'un gamin lorsqu'il est
posé tranquillement est-ce que vous
pensez que voilà une voiture de police
pas s'il va comme ça jeté un projectile
ou autre non c'est quelque chose qui va
comme ça crescendo c'est à dire que leur
comportement
le comportement de ces jeunes lorsqu'ils
on arrive à commettre des actes de
violence comme comme ceux ci c'est parce
que derrière ils se prennent au
quotidien les violences et on parle de
violences policières mais moi j'ai
surtout envie de parler de cette date la
violence originelle la violence
originelle qui permet qui permet et qui
légitime la violence policière
là on va parler en fait des violences
étatiques et les violences s'étaient
fixés les institutions c'est à dire que
à partir du moment où on a un système
judiciaire et juridique qui ne punit pas
lorsqu'il ya des violences policières
qui vont jusqu'à causer la mort le
sentiment d'impunité qui est grandissant
comment auprès de certains
fonctionnaires de police alors j'ai
juste essayé ça j'aimerais poser une
question à david le bas david on entend
de son cloche en optant voilà iessa
cayla qui nous dit il ya une présence
policière qui est qui et est oppressante
pour les jeunes dans ces quartiers et on
entend d'un autre côté on entend aussi
les policiers la police ne va plus dans
les banlieues ne va plus dans les cités
à risque parce que de peur de se faire
caillasser de se faire damner donc là on
a de son cru c'est quoi la vérité la
vérité c'est d'abord de rappeler
pourquoi il ya la police la police elle
est partout en france pas seulement dans
certains quartiers se lier celui ou ceux
que vous connaissez
elle y est partout dans une mission que
tout le monde connaît ces deux
lutter contre la délinquance donc soin
de chercher les infractions soit
rechercher les auteurs de ces
infractions
donc on est d'accord oui aussi protéger
et servir se courir aussi on est passé
en avant d'ailleurs vous avez raison
vous me lancer sur un sujet on critique
souvent la police sur son volet
répressif on oublie son côté social
protecteur secours on n'est pas assez là
dessus sur la communication mais ça ça
fait partie des torts qu'on a pour qu'on
démarre à être d'accord
on n'est pas là en train de demander
vous et moi en tout cas pas moi parce
que je parle au nom de la police de
retirer la police des quartiers ou alors
me laissez pas croire en tant que
policier que c'est la présence policière
qui justifie les violences mais est-ce
que si la simple présence policière
justifier les violences là je serais pas
d'accord avec vous en revanche si vous
pensez qu'il ya des problèmes de forme
de façon de contrôler et de s'adresser
aux jeunes de contrôler certaines
personnes plutôt que d'autres là là
dessus on aura un débat où on pourra
avancer et blanc tandis à lorient survie
dollars moi je fais en sorte de dénoncer
dans ce livre c'est très permet
d'avancer et ouvrir des pistes pour que
nous mêmes en prennent note pas où vous
essayez aussi voilà de dire voilà il
faut il faut vous essayer de dialoguer
aussi avec se jette et et voilà essayer
de savoir comment on les appréhender et
comme on peut les approuver pour qu on
le fasse avancer les choses n'ont peur
de rien dit ce que dit gay ça moi et je
comprends ce qu'elle dit et ça elle nie
c'est vrai qu'il ya des jeunes contre
les contrôles une fois deux fois trois
fois la grille et que paris et qu'à un
moment un moment on sait comment ça se
passe ça voilà ça c'est vrai que les
jeunes de leur côté et ils parlent mal
les policiers d'un autre côté ils
parlent mal ya un manque de respect
mutuel voilà des deux côtés et c'est
vrai qu'à un moment on sait plus on sait
plus qui a commencé mais c'est vrai que
les policiers aussi il y en avait aussi
voilà il ya des gars les forces de
l'ordre quand on dit voilà il va lutter
partout et je comprends ce que vous
dites aussi c'est un moment il ya des
jeunes ils n'en peuvent plus on est
tranquille en train de voix la dette
avec des potes et on se fait contrôler
deux trois quatre fois dans la journée à
l'impression de ne pas être libre six
caisses comment vous le sentez ça vous
le sentez ça ou pas je le sens
parfaitement bien d'autant plus que je
suis d'accord est ce que vous venez de
dire mais il faut qu'on partage le
constat pour être d'accord sur le fait
que les torts on va pas dire les torts
sont partagés ou un partout il ya des
torts qu'ils existent aussi bien chez
les jeunes qui sont parfois à l'origine
de violences cupides et gratuite sans
aucun motif
il ya de la délinquance il ya des gens
qui se comportent mal dans la société et
il existe aussi des policiers qui
peuvent mal se comporter
moi je reconnais que des comportements
peuvent être inappropriés pour la police
mais si vous vous restez sur une
position qui est la violence des jeunes
vis-à-vis de la police c'est parce que
la police est présente ça peut pas être
une justification si vous reconnaissez
pas aussi qu'il ya des problèmes la
remise des comportements